li tonnes de haschich sur un quai de
marseille c'est la plus importante prise
de cette drogue jamais réalisée en
france
mais les trafiquants n'étaient pas au
rendez vous la pologne entre le choc et
la prière les pros policiers qui ont
enlevé le père popieluszko avoue l'avoir
jeté dans la vistule
les prix du pétrole en chute libre les
pays producteurs de l'opep se réunissent
à genève
rive droite rive gauche c'est le nouveau
film de philippe labro qui sort mercredi
invité de ce journal son héroïne
nathalie baye
monsieur bonsoir vendredi dernier un
cargo qui venait du liban des charges
sur le port de marseille
un conteneur un conteneur plein de
haschich ni tonnes soit une valeur
marchande de quelque 200 millions de
francs
les policiers marseillais avait mise en
place de longue date un filet pour
s'emparer des destinataires de la
marchandise mais la presse locale a eu
trop tôt avant de la faire et les
trafiquants ne sont jamais venus au
rendez vous sur place à marseille
dominique tierces les policiers les
douaniers de marseille devrait être fier
grâce à un travail de fourmi un
excellent réseau d'informateurs ils ont
saisi hier soir 10 tonnes de haschich du
jamais vu en france
pourtant on se félicite me au srpj ni
dans les bureaux de la douane de marcel
la sphère remonte à vendredi soir
policiers douaniers singe que la drogue
doit être entreposés dans un hangar un
dispositif détroit de surveillance est
installé les enquêteurs veulent mettre
la main sur les commanditaires de la
drogue
ils attendent 24 heures 48 heures
personne ne se présente tout lundi matin
ils saisissent la drogue
déçu et furieux furieux car les
trafiquants pourrait très bien avoir été
informé tout simplement par un article
du méridional
dès dimanche matin cet article annoncé
la belle prise et même avec un peu trop
d' avance de nombreuses arrestations
bref c'est une fuite bien maladroite qui
selon les enquêteurs à empêcher un joli
coup de filet reste maintenant à en
trouver l'auteur
c'est à midi par la radio officielle que
les polonais qui porte déjà le deuil du
père popieluszko ont appris que ses
ravisseurs trois policiers travaillant
pour le ministère de l'intérieur avait
avoué avoir jeté le prêtre de choc dans
la vistule
les recherches se poursuivent pour
retrouver son corps mais les autorités
n'osent pas encore parler de morts
la pologne s'est cependant qu'elle
compte un nouveau martyr
même si les cheval et a souscrit en même
temps que le numéro un du régime
polonais à la thèse du complot bon hit
werther les dernières révélations ne
sont pas fait pour apaiser les esprits
pour tenter de calmer les fidèles
exaspéré monseigneur blême le primat de
pologne prêché et hier soir à la
cathédrale de varsovie 10 ans dans ces
moments difficiles que nous polonais
vivent douloureusement nous devons aimer
notre prochain comme nous mêmes ils
étaient 1500 l'écouté mais ils étaient
cinquante mille les fidèles qui se
pressaient dans l'église de saint
venceslas et surtout autour de l'église
tient qu'à service d'ordre exceptionnel
de la police et tenté de les dissuader
s'avance et cela c'est la paroisse du
père popieluszko hier comme tous les
derniers dimanches du mois
l'officiant célébrer la messe pour la
paix dans son prêche il tente de
réconforter la foule en disant si le
père popieluszko était là ils vous
diraient ne vous soumettez pas lutter
contre le mal en faisant le bien le
portrait du père était suspendu sur la
façade de l'église sur l'autel un
tableau représentant saint georges jersy
en polonais quel prénom du père porte
lescot saint georges terrassant le
dragon
l'appel au calme lancé hier par lech
walesa a été entendu
il n'y a pas eu grève aujourd'hui aux
aciéries de varsovie une fois de plus
ils se retrouvent à genève en pleine
fièvre pétrolières les ministres de
l'opep mais aussi les experts et les
représentants des compagnies pétrolières
fanny et des palabres dans les grands
hôtels
leur objectif cette fois enrayer la
chute des prix qui menace d'effondrement
le marché pétrolier l'objectif est clair
mais les moyens le sont moins à genève
laurence er mai on attendait avec peu
hésité l'arrivée du ministre du pétrole
du nigeria ici à genève à la réunion de
l'opep
une réunion qui ne croit principe décidé
de réduire la production de pétrole au
sein de l'opep afin de défendre le prix
officiel du baril de pétrole brut
aujourd'hui menacé le ministre du
nigeria mme chez david west est arrivé
et il a déclaré le pétrole c'est la vie
du nigeria et le ter du nigeria de
continuer à pomper traduction ne comptez
pas sur nous pour réduire notre
production à la sortie de la première
rencontre les 13 pays de l'opep
les sourires du chèque yamani d'arabie
saoudite caché mal un certain embarras
pour un indonésien monsieur bretons il
faut rétablir et renforcer la discipline
au sein de l'opep
une allusion qui visent directement le
nigeria
le nigeria souffre particulièrement de
la récession du marché pétrolier et les
très endetté et il tire 90% de ses
revenus du pétrole
et il subit une forte concurrence
pétrole de la mer du nord qui vient de
baisser alors le nigérien à décider sans
consulter l'opecst de baisser le prix de
son propre pétrole est une nouvelle
brèche une nouvelle crise s'est ouverte
au sein de l'opep
l'opep dont l'influencé ne cesse de
diminuer sur le marché du pétrole mais
dont les soubresauts sont suivi avec
inquiétude car rien n'est plus dangereux
qu'un marché du pétrole qui serait
plongé dans le chaos lopez vient de
décider ce soir de réduire son plafond
de production le plafond de production
est ramenée à 16 millions de barils jour
mais quelle que soit l'issue finale de
cette conférence
le prix des produits pétroliers en
france n'en sera pas pour autant
affecter en tout cas pour les
consommateurs
les explications des gendarmes
l'automobiliste français regardent les
réunions de l'opep sans trop d'illusions
persuadé que de toute façon il devra
sûrement payer son essence plus cher à
l'opep à genève
ils ont peut-être décidé d'une baisse de
la production et d'une baisse du prix du
pétrole est ce que vous pensez que ça va
se répercuter sur la pompe
non
comment parce que les temps recherché à
prendre des peintres vois vraiment pas
pourquoi dans les conditions actuelles
elle baisserait parce que l'argent le
gouvernement a beaucoup ont besoin
d'argent l'heure actuelle en france
c'est une tradition l'essence a toujours
été fortement taxés à cela s'ajoute la
hausse du dollar
rappelons que la facture pétrolière
payés en dollars présentera cette année
160 milliards de francs mais si la
baisse décidée par trois pays
producteurs été suivi par l'ensemble des
pays de l'opep cela pourrait être
bénéfique pour la france
si cet exemple devait être suivie il est
bien certain que la facture pétrolière
d'un pays comme la france diminuent ray
mais je ne peux pas dire un priori
quelle serait la répartition de cette
baisse entre les différentes parties
prenantes c'est à dire l'état le fisc
les sociétés de raffinage et le
consommateur mais je pense néanmoins
selon toute vraisemblance que le
consommateurs verrait le prix de
l'essence à la pompe baisser de quelques
centimes par litre penser qu'il y aurait
donc une conséquence à la baisse si bien
entendu l'état de désir pas confisqué à
son profit le bénéfice correspondant et
pour les compagnies pétrolères est ce
qu'il y aura une baisse aussi dans ce
cas là est bien pour les sociétés
productrices
indéniablement les sociétés productrices
gagne d'autant plus d'argent que le
produit qu'elle produisait qu'elles
vendent et plus cher pour une société
comme le groupe f une baisse d'1 dollar
par baril représente une moins-value
annuel de plus d'un milliard de francs
on le constate quelle que soit la
décision des pays producteurs elle ne
satisfera pas tout le monde notamment
les automobilistes et les compagnies
pétrolières qui pensent perdre encore de
l'argent
pour l'instant on attend donc de
connaître ce que vont décider les pays
producteurs pour savoir combien nous
perdons notre sens
l'impact de la facture pétrolière est
d'autant plus complexe qu'elle se paie
en dollars la devise américaine est à
nouveau à la hausse et la côte et 9
francs 39 aujourd'hui à paris les
banques qui depuis 12 ans vous faisait
crédits dans le cadre d'un système très
strictes instauré par l'état les banques
vont retrouver le chemin de la
concurrence ministre de l'économie et
des finances pierre bérégovoy en effet
annoncé ce matin que le système
d'encadrement du crédit
sera supprimée à partir du 1er janvier
mais l'état n'abandonne pas pour autant
tout contrôle philippe sella vous ce n'a
pas encore réagi aux mesures annoncées
ce matin par pierre bérégovoy elle
attend d'en connaître exactement tous
les détails
le nouveau principe est le suivant à
partir du 1er janvier les banques
accorderont des crédits non plus en
fonction d'un quota l'encadrement
mais selon les ressources qu'elles
seront se procurer le ministre des
finances voilà un moyen de faire baisser
le coût du crédit
toutes ces mesures ont pour but de
diminuer le prix du crédit
et puis un particulier ou une entreprise
pourra demain mieux plaider sa demande
de crédit auprès de la banque sans se
voir opposer l'encadrement qui vient
d'en haut
vivien du gouvernement et donc on ne
sait pas très bien à quoi il répond dans
les milieux financiers on se montre
officieusement plus réservé sur la
possibilité d'une baisse du coût du
crédit mais c'est vrai il y aura
davantage de concurrence entre les
banques ce qui pourrait effectivement
conduire en période de faible demande de
crédit à une légère baisse des taux sa
mise en place d'un nouveau système plus
simple
il se fonde en effet sur la
responsabilité la qualité de la gestion
obligera les banques pour développer
leurs crédits avoir une capacité
bénéficiaire accrue l'argent en plus
c'est l'argent moins cher c'est un autre
aspect des choses ça n'est pas l'aspect
purement monétaires puisque nous sommes
dans le cadre d'une norme monétaire
définies par le gouvernement et les
autorités il appartiendra simplement aux
banques de faire en sorte que la
compétition entre elles permettent de
mieux servir le client mais de tenir
compte aussi c'est le nouvel élément
important de la capacité bénéficiaire
faut-il par exemple attendre de ceux des
encadrements partiel davantage d'argent
pour les chantiers de construction
a priori non car l'état en contrôlant
étroitement l'évolution de ce qu'on
appelle la masse monétaire ne lâche pas
la bride au crédit le nouveau système
est plus simple plus moderne mais il ne
faut pas s'attendre à ce que d'un coup
de baguette magique l'argent redevienne
abondant et bon marché
l'actualité politique ce soir se noue
derrière les portes closes de la place
du colonel fabien à paris
le comité central du parti communiste se
réunit jusqu'à demain
à huis clos pour examiner le projet de
résolution qui doit servir de base au
congrès de février prochain en toile de
fond des luttes d'influencé sinon de
courant comme explique dominique chez le
comité central examine le document
préparatoire au 25ème congrès c'est en
fait le débat sur l'avenir du pc qui a
repris ce matin un débat qui au fil des
semaines laissent apparaître malgré le
huis clos des divergences de plus en
plus profondes au sein même de
l'appareil
du côté des rénovateurs fiterman rigou
le pors juquin c'est la tante une
contestation qui cherche encore ses
marques sa ligne de conduite à la
direction apparemment soudée autour de
georges marchais les rivalités se font
jour
favorisé par les tâtonnements en matière
de stratégie du secrétaire général dans
cette confusion aggravée par des échecs
répétés le camouflet de l'urss sur la
féra bouchard la modeste marche de la
paix un homme semble s'affirmer
le directeur de l'humanité roland leroy
tente une nouvelle percée après avoir
été écarté du secrétariat du parti au
dernier congrès le jeu personnel de
roland leroy me rappelle celui de
raymond barre au sein de l'opposition
disait ironiquement ce matin un membre
du comité central à la réflexion il y a
peut être du vrai dans cette boutade oui
à la cavitation en cas de grand succès
non en cas de petites victoires
telle est la contribution de madame
simone veil qui était toute à l'heure
l'invité de france inter au débat sur
une éventuelle cohabitation entre le
chef de l'état et l'opposition en cas de
sa victoire aux législatives
madame veil a précisé que
personnellement elle ne s'allierait ni
avec jospin ni avec le pen fin de
citation jacques chirac s'en va-t-en
guerre contre l'avortement dans un
entretien que publiera demain le journal
libération le président du rpr estime
que la démographie en france est menacée
par la banalisation des interruptions
volontaires de grossesse il souhaite un
réexamen de la législation actuelle en
matière de contraception et d'avortement
en même temps que la définition d'une
véritable politique familiale avec par
exemple l'octroi d'une prime au
troisième enfant
arthur cet après-midi dans une petite
station thermale allemande du 44e sommet
franco allemand
un sommet qui pour le chancelier kohl a
lieu à l'ombre du scandale financier qui
ébranle son gouvernement
un sommet qui pour le président
mitterrand s'inscrit sous le signe des
difficultés de certains projets de
coopération bilatérale sur place george
monbiot spécialité de bad kreuznach
les rhumatismes une de ces gentilles
petites villes aux allemandes où les
curistes viennent tenter de débloquer
leur articulation rhumatisante deuxième
spécialité de bad kreuznach
les grandes rencontres politiques c'est
ici que de gaulle et adenauer se sont
rencontrés en 1958 pour amorcer la
grande réconciliation franco allemande
helmut kohl se veut l'héritier politique
d'aller l'horaire mais aujourd'hui cet
art et mode cool affaiblie par le
scandale politico financier qui secoue
l'allemagne officiels en dépit des
apparences donc les deux interlocuteurs
de ce sommet ne marche pas tout à fait
du même pas car si les péripéties de
politique intérieure influe peu ou pas
sur les orientations de la politique
extérieure de françois mitterrand
monsieur cole en revanche qu'ils ne
maîtrisent pas toujours très bien son
propre gouvernement a aujourd'hui moins
d'autorité pour faire aboutir certains
projets franco-allemands
on va voir par exemple si ces entretiens
vont permettre de débloquer le projet de
satellite d'observation franco-allemand
qu'on croyait définitivement acquis
après l'entretien de rambouillet et qui
maintenant rencontrent certaines
réticences du côté allemand où on juge
que la technique proposée celle de
l'observation optique ne serait pas
assez performante
on se penchera également avec beaucoup
d'intérêt et toujours dans le domaine
spatial sur le projet ariane 5
tout de même au cours de leur entretien
de 1958 de gaulle et adenauer ces
précurseurs aurait-il rêver des projets
communs aussi ambitieux
ce matin à l'elysée ce sont les
problèmes du proche orient que les chef
de l'état a évoqué avec son hôte
président égyptien hosni moubarak les
problèmes du proche orient mais aussi de
l'afrique et notamment du tchad
au tchad les militaires français ont
terminé leur évacuation de leur poste
avancé ils sont maintenant regroupés
dans la capitale le porte parole
militaire français déclarent n'avoir
aucune information sur l'arrivée des
observateurs libyen prévu par l'accord
de désengagement entre paris et tripoli
la france s'apprête à envoyer 15 tonnes
de céréales aux victimes de la
sécheresse en ethiopie
c'est ce qu'a annoncé aujourd'hui le
ministère de la coopération
la famine vous le savez frappent là bas
quelques six millions de personnes
c'est un véritable arsenal qui a été
découvert ce matin dans les caves des
hospices civils de strasbourg
un obus a éclaté tuant un homme
emmanuel vanille une tonne d'explosifs
de tous calibres
on ne saura jamais quel cauchemar de
guerre hantent et ramon fric 50 ans qui
à l'insu de tous pendant des mois peut
être des années à entreposer dans les
sous sols de cet hôpital
de quoi faire sauter le centre ville de
strasbourg on ne connaîtra jamais les
raisons profondes de ce maniaque discret
gentil selon ses collègues il est mort
ce matin en manipulant anobile décédé
parce qu'elle manipulait un détonateur
ou des engins explosifs
parce que c'est probablement en train de
scier un engin explosif et assia il a dû
chauffer
ramon fritsch était un technicien de la
faculté de médecine qui utilisait ses
locaux sous l'hôpital
on a retrouvé à son domicile dans une
armoire 150 autres engins de guerre
l'hôpital est évacué en partie les
opérations de déminage au vu de
l'importance du stock vont durer
plusieurs jours
les trois derniers détenus d'extrême
gauche qui poursuivait une grève de la
faim depuis le 15 septembre dernier ont
recommencé à s'alimenter
parmi eux claude halfen membres présumés
d'action directe
par ailleurs les gardiens de prisons
poursuivre leur mouvement déclenché
lundi dernier par quatre syndicats
pénitentiaires
ils bloquent les portes des prisons pour
empêcher extraction transfèrement ou
écrou le mouvement est inacceptable et
inégale a déclaré aujourd'hui la
chancellerie à montpellier hier matin un
match de football amical opposé deux
équipes locales l'arbitré mort abattu de
deux coups de fusil
jérôme baugnies hier matin dans ce stade
l'ambiance du match est d'abord plutôt
chaleureuse mais pendant la deuxième mi
temps 3 gitans venus d'une cité voisine
pénètrent sur le terrain l'arbitré c'est
de les expulser
le ton monte il gifle l'un d'entre eux
un dénommé roanne qui part en criant on
aura quelques minutes plus tard alors
que le match continue roanne ce poste au
bord du terrain et pour la fusée de
chasse et à bas les jeunes arbitres
profitant de la confusion
le meurtrier disparaît ensuite dans
cette cité la cité chantal où vivent de
nombreux gîtes en ya souvent des
bagarres cela ici ouais
ouais
et pourquoi des bagarres on est mauvais
en conviant
ici plus que les inspire plus souvent
mises en vente à nokia pour agir et
mettrez si on n'agit pas au 21 de quoi
le deuxième drame
où il faut déménager qu'on aille habitat
et à sahnayah tout fuit parce que tout
c'est le nerf est en colère et révolté
par l'histoire comme ça c'est vraiment
inadmissible avant qu'il parte à tout
prix et on veut surtout l'une a frappé
quand il était le chef de la sûreté de
montpellier a bien du mal à faire
avancer l'enquêté le meurtrier a sans
doute trouvé refuge dans une autre cité
de gitans loin de montpellier pendant
toute la journée ses proches ont été
interrogés par la police mais sans
résultat ils se barricadent tous
derrière la loi du silence
l' enquête sur la mort du petit grégory
entre dans sa troisième semaine les
policiers pensent avoir identifié une
femme par son écriture est un homme par
sa voix ils seraient tous deux employés
dans une filature et les policiers
attendent de réunir des preuves plus
formelle pour procéder à des
inculpations
joséphine a perdu son insouciance
d'enfants elle ne cesse de faire des
cauchemars et mon bonheur de vivre a été
interrompue c'est en ces termes que
frédéric dard très émue est passé du
roman policier à la cour d'assises de
genève aujourd'hui pour témoigner au
procès du ravisseur de ses filles un
enlèvement contre rançon qui eut lieu en
mars 83 et pour lequel est jugé
un caméraman cambrioleurs françoise
champeaux
deux semaines pour vivre cinq jours
d'angoissé d'élite d'art l'auteur de san
antonio et son épouse se sont retrouvés
ce matin en face des douars bois de
chêne accusait du rapt de leur fille
joséphine âgée aujourd'hui de 13 ans
pour enlever la petite fille bois de
chêne avait minutieusement préparé son
scénario
dans la nuit du 22 mars 1983 il pénètre
à l'aide d'une échelle dans la chambre
de joséphine lui administre une piqûre
de chloroforme et des soporifiques 25
heures plus tard le ravisseur se
manifeste ils réclament une rançon de
deux millions de francs suisses soit
près de 8 millions de francs français en
petites coupures usagées
le rendez vous est fixé trois heures du
matin frédéric dard seront sur les bords
du rhône avec 2000 billets de 1000
francs dans un sac plastique et la
croche à un ingénieux système de poulie
relié à l'autre rive de la rivière
pendant plus de 48 heures la petite
joséphine a été séquestrée dans cette
caravane drogués à plusieurs reprises
elle parviendra quand même à s'enfuir et
sera recueillie par un automobiliste
je n'arrive pas lui en vouloir parce
qu'il m'a rendu ce qui m'avait volé et
il aurait pu ne pas le faire je vous
allez dire que j'ai un drôle de
raisonnement mais je suis tellement
heureux d'avoir retrouvé ma fille c'est
un tel n'appelons pas ça du bonheur
c'est celle univers qui recommence qui
continue que pourquoi le vent
voudrais-je il a suffi de cinq jours
pour arrêter edouard bois de chêne la
rançon a été intégralement récupérer
ainsi que toutes les pièces à conviction
en particulier le masque utilisé pour
l'enlèvement bois de chêne 47 ans était
un caméraman de la télévision suisse
avant de commettre cet enlèvement il
avait déjà cambriolé 35 châteaux et
résidences cossues selon des scénarios
analogue amour de sport et de formule 1
jacques laffite retourne à l'écurie
ligier
après deux années passées chez williams
lafitte pilotera la saison prochaine
la ligier
js 25 aux côtés de l'italien andrea de
cesaris ils étaient dix-huit mille trois
cent soixante cinq sur la ligne de
départ hier à new york pour le marathon
lui il a terminé 5680 11e après un peu
plus de quatre heures d'une course
épuisante une course endeuillée par la
mort d'un homme français de 48 ans
victime d'une crise cardiaque
françois léotard secrétaire général du
parti républicain et maire de fréjus
raconte sa course à jean-louis calmer
jeune c'était sur 96 étaient très durs
pour tout le monde on a beaucoup
souffert
savez-vous quel coureur français a eu un
accident cardiaque pendant la course
oui je les a pris en revenant et cela a
beaucoup ternie comment ça s'est passé
j'ai appris depuis que pensez vous de
ces courants mal préparés qu'ils
encourent des risques pendant ce genre
de compétition on m'a dit avec
l'exclusion marathon mais avait
également eu des accidents cardiaques
sais pas si c'est vrai et c'est pas plus
mal et je crois qu'il faut être
effectivement prendre toutes les 48 et
tout le monde souligne qu' on est apte à
86 millièmes coureurs de parra contre
york était la première fois qu elle
compte maintenant parmi les toutes
premières actrices françaises
l'hebdomadaire américain newsweek en a
même fait le symbole du jeune cinéma
français en lui consacrant récemment sa
couverture nathalie baye est l'héroïne
du film de philippe labro qui sort sur
les écrans mercredi prochain nathalie
van soir avant de parler du film et de
votre rôle
un extrait de ce film où l'on vous voit
avec le héros du film qui n'est autre
que gérard depardieu pas naturel que
dans ce décor unique monsieur le
président directeur général de
métrologie
monsieur antoine macquart ait voulu
offrir à ses amis
guignol il ya vous mesdames et messieurs
la primeur de son nouveau produit
quoi qu'il en soit mesdames et messieurs
si l'art et la culture on avait perdu
quelque chose de l'argent il est clair
si je trouve puisque même beaucoup plus
besoin de la lys et moi ça va pas nous
en révolutionnant les foyers qu'il faut
pas apporter aux familles une nouvelle
façon de vie est il le mieux être
reconnaissant à métrologie d'avoir
contribué à la restauration
c'est le genre de truc qui doit marcher
le samedi soir avec les boudins goût
draguer alors nathalie baye gérard
depardieu le couple au choc de rive
droite rive gauche
c'est une histoire d'amour bien sûr une
histoire où vous incarnez une jeune
femme bien aujourd'hui
oui ça m'a beaucoup plu parce que ça
faisait très longtemps que j'avais pas
jouer un personnage complètement de
maintenant elle et elle fait de la
relation publique et du restaurant tout
le film on lui dit mais qu'est ce que
c'est que la relation qu musique et
c'est agaçant et la définition bien
précise de la chose n'ira pas oui ça
n'importe quelle extrémité pour faire ce
métier non elle a envie d'être en accord
avec elle même elle a envie d'être bien
dans sa peau et elle refuse les
compromis je crois que c'est pas très
facile alors pour vous est-ce que c'est
un nouveau stéréotypes féminins les
laits la femme libérée sûre d'elle qui
vit sa vie parce que dans ce film on
voit finalement gérard depardieu quitté
carole bouquet pour vous ce sont quand
même deux stéréotypes féminins bien bien
différent parce que carole bouquet joue
l'avant on peut superbe
oui il est très belle
les formidables dans le film et vous
aussi non mais je pense que c'est il ya
aussi une lassitude c'est un couple qui
n'arrive plus à se parler il travaille
il travaille énormément il est mal dans
sa peau il fait des choses qui ne sont
pas bien il en a marre et défend un type
qui est un [ __ ] et il se demande si
lui même est un [ __ ] voilà c'est ça le
sujet un moment il rencontre une femme
il tombe amoureux de cette femme qui le
personnage que je joue et ça lui donne
des ailes et ça me donne du courage et
c'est un amour de maturité aussi joui
pas un amour de jeunes gens oui mais
c'est pour ça c'est assez drôle parce
que je pense que quand on a 20 ans quand
tombe amoureux c'est souvent très
sinistre on est très sérieux étant dit
quand on a 30 ans on a reçus d'un coup
de bâton sur la tête on est presque plus
joyeux alors vous vouliez c'est une
histoire d'amour mais c'est aussi
l'histoire d'un homme qui tout à coup
découvre qu'il doit se battre pour la
vérité alors c'est finalement une
histoire très mal de philippe labro sur
un fond très doré dans un paris super
ans mais c'est très moral c'est vrai
mais c'est ce que j'ai bien aimé dans
l'histoire et mais ils valent ça va être
difficile parce qu'ils valent on va lui
faire payer son honnêteté
pourquoi et bien parce que je crois que
c'est pas facile de dire la vérité quand
on entend surtout quand on fait ce
métier il ya des méchants
il ya des migrantes il est méchant et ça
se termine un peu comme un thriller bien
je peux je vais pas raconter la fin
n'ont surtout pas et les histoires
morale vous aimez ça notamment temps oui
je trouve que c'est bien
et ce soir vous allez aux ennemis moi je
n'y arrivais non parce que ce soir c'est
relâche mais demain j'irai m'entraîner
nathalie baye merci et maintenant alain
gillot-pétré qui on est tout ému il va
nous parler du temps où il n'y a pas que
moi il ya aussi la caméra qui est ému
puisque oui la voilà la caméra bonjour
mais l'esprit le ciel état est
stationnaire regardez la photo satellite
anticyclone tient bon il est toujours
sur l'europe occidentale il protège
toujours la france des perturbations
atlantiques
cela dit est tout de même cette
perturbation ci qui va demain commencé à
pénétrer sur le pays mais très très
lentement il ya également tous ces
nuages qui mijote en méditerranée et qui
sont susceptibles comme aujourd'hui
d'apporter quelques averses orageuses en
corse mais dans l'ensemble ça ne bouge
pas trop ça bougera d'ici jeudi
regardez la carte de demain beaucoup de
brouillard beaucoup de nuages bas dès le
matin partout mais ensuite ce sera du
beau temps beau temps sur la moitié sud
du pays juste
kohno reste sourd brouillard persistant
bien entendu dans quelques vallées à
l'exception de la corse
puisqu'on est au sud de la france où il
ya impossibilité d'averses orageuses
accompagnées le renforcement des vents
de nord-est côté nord-ouest là un peu
plus de nuages nettement plus même un
peu moins d'éclaircies nettement moins
est beaucoup plus de nuages en fin de
journée par les côtes du cotentin et de
la bretagne avec cette faible zone
depuis qui très lentement pénétrera en
france avec un baromètre en baisse et
internet qui lui monte
nous allons de 12 à 17 degrés sur la
moitié nord 18 sur nivelle nantes lors
de la loire et de 16 à 22 degrés sur la
moitié sud 22 degrés à biarritz demain
trois minutes de travail au moins pour
ce mardi 30 octobre le vestiaire quand
quatre coachs et 17h33 et bonne fête à
toutes les bienvenues ce qui est valable
pour tous les téléspectateurs mantel de
bien sûr bien sûr 23h10 c'était avec
l'autre qui vous présentera notre
dernière édition demain 12h45 antenne
2010 18h30 c'est la vie et je vous
retrouverai avec plaisir demain à 20
heures
très bonne soirée
à